هذا ما تبدو عليه أزمة الفيروس التاجي
مثل سيارة إسعاف تنقل
مريضًا إلى غرفة الطوارئ في
المستعمرة البرتغالية السابقة الصغيرة في ماكاو
للعاملين الصحيين المحميين تمامًا
ضد المرض الجديد ، فإن السلطات في
ماكاو لا تأخذ أي فرصة
لإبلاغ الجمهور بأنه إذا  كنت تشك في
أن لديك أعراض فيروس كورونا
وأنك كنت على اتصال بشخص
تخشى أنه قد يكون مريضًا أيضًا في مكان ما
في الصين القارية ، اتصل بسيارة
إسعاف ستوصلك هنا إلى
مدخل الطوارئ لصور المستشفى العام الرئيسية في المدينة
من  داخل
جناح العزل ، يتم علاج ما لا يقل عن سبعة مرضى
هنا
، وكان للطوارئ الصحية تأثير مذهل على
هذه الزاوية شبه المستقلة من الصين
ماكاو مع عدد سكانها الصغير الذي يبلغ
حوالي 600000 شخص ، وعادة ما تكون
نقطة جذب رئيسية للسياحة تستقبل ما يقرب من
40 مليون زائر العام الماضي
وحدها الكازينوهات الشاهقة في ماكاو
هي عاصمة المقامرة في العالم
مع صناعة الكازينو  تلك الأقزام في لاس
فيجاس ولكن منذ تفشي فيروس كورونا ،
انخفضت السياحة إلى ماكاو بنسبة 87
في المائة في يناير مقارنة
بالعام السابق ، لم أرها
فارغة من قبل ، نعم لم أر قط
شيئًا مثل هذا ألفين أو مارتينيز هو
خبير اقتصادي برتغالي يقيم منذ فترة طويلة في
ماكاو ، تذهب إلى الشوارع ، لم أر
الشوارع فارغة مطلقًا ، تذهب إلى الساحة الرئيسية
فارغة تمامًا ، لم أر هذا مطلقًا في
حياتي وأنا هنا منذ عام 1981 ،
ولم أظن أبدًا أن الناس
خائفون ربما بسبب سرعة
هذه العدوى  تقول سلطات ماكاو
إنها جمعت كل
زائر من مقاطعة
هيبي الصينية أصل فيروس كورونا ،
هؤلاء الناس لديهم خيار إما
مغادرة الإقليم أو الذهاب
إلى الحجر الصحي ،
لكنهم يرسمون خطاً عندما
يتعلق الأمر بالمحرك الأساسي لـ  اقتصاد المدينة
الذي لا يستبعد أحد تدابيرك الصحية
هذا الاحتمال في
وزير الاقتصاد بالمدينة
ولكن في هذه المرحلة من الوقت ، فإن الكازينوهات في
ماكاو  حليف آمن في الوقت الحالي
لا تزال بيوت المقامرة البراقة في ماكاو
مفتوحة ولكن مثل باقي الصين ، هذه
المدينة تكافح مع الفيروس الجديد
ويتفق الجميع هنا على أن هذه
مجرد بداية للأزمة
، التحدي الكبير التالي للسلطات الصينية
هو التعامل مع هذه
العطلة التالية  أزمة السفر الآن تذكر أن
العطلة الوطنية للاحتفال بالعام القمري
الجديد ستنتهي رسميًا يوم الأحد
مما يعني أن ملايين
الأشخاص سيتنقلون مرة أخرى للعودة إلى ديارهم بعد
زيارة العائلة والأصدقاء
والسفر إلى مكان آخر
الآن ستكون أزمة السفر هذه أصغر من
حيث الحجم مقارنةً بـ  ما سيكون عليه الأمر في
العادة لأنه تذكر أن الكثير من
الحكومات المحلية قد أعلنت عن مزيد من
التأخير في إعادة فتح مدارسها وأعمالها ،
ولكن لا تزال هذه هي الصين ، فنحن
نتحدث عن 1.4 مليار شخص ، لذا حتى
على نطاق أصغر ، هناك ملايين
الأشخاص الذين يتنقلون للتعامل مع  في هذه القضية
، عززت السلطات عمليات
الفحص وتشديد الإجراءات الأخرى في
مراكز النقل حول ج  بلد
على سبيل المثال ، صرحت هيئة السكك الحديدية في بكين
أنها قامت
بوضع طاقم طبي مناسب من المواد الخطرة على
أهبة الاستعداد في الأيام القليلة الماضية ،
وقد تم إرسال هؤلاء الموظفين الطبيين إلى
منصات محطات القطار كلما
تلقوا تقارير عن أشخاص تظهر عليهم
أعراض الفيروس على متن الطائرة.  لذلك كان هؤلاء
الموظفون قادرين على المساعدة في إخلاء
القطارات أثناء نقل هذه
الحالات المشتبه فيها إلى منشآت مخصصة
لإجراء مزيد من الفحوصات
والحجر الصحي المحتمل الآن ، شيء واحد حول هذا
الفيروس هو أنه يتحول إلى العالمية مع
الإعلان من
منظمة الصحة العالمية التي تصنف هذا الفاشية على أنها حالة طوارئ صحية عالمية
يقوم المزيد والمزيد من
شركات الطيران الدولية أيضًا بإلغاء تعليق
الخدمات من وإلى الصين ، مما
تسبب في الكثير من المشاكل للمسافرين الصينيين
بالإضافة إلى العديد منهم
الذين تقطعت بهم السبل في الخارج وخاصة أولئك من
مركز الزلزال ، لذا لمعالجة هذه المشكلة
، أعلنت الحكومة الصينية
أنها ستفعل ذلك.  يتم إرسال
رحلات طيران مستأجرة خاصة إلى ديستينا في الخارج
لالتقاط هؤلاء الركاب الذين يسافرون معهم إلى الوطن
، وقد أعلنوا بالفعل عن رحلتين من هذا القبيل
يوم الجمعة ، واحدة إلى تايلاند واحدة إلى
ماليزيا لنقل الركاب الذين تقطعت بهم السبل
وإعادتهم إلى هان
أحد الأشياء التي غالبًا ما
يتم طرحها وتمت مناقشتها  الكثير هو كيف يمكن
مقارنة هذا بأشياء أخرى ، على سبيل المثال ،
الأنفلونزا ، نعلم جيدًا أن الأنفلونزا على سبيل المثال في
هذا البلد بالفعل
قتل هذا الموسم بالذات أكثر من 8000 شخص
وكان هناك الملايين
والملايين من الإصابات عندما تنظر إلى
هذا الفيروس الآن في جميع أنحاء  العالم الذي
تشاهده ما يقرب من 10000 شخص
مصاب ومن الواضح أنك تعرف 200 شخص
أو أكثر ممن لقوا حتفهم ، فالأرقام
مختلفة حقًا ولكن مع وجود
فيروس جديد لا نعرف ببساطة كيف
ستسير الأمور
فيروس جديد تمامًا لا يزال هناك الكثير من
الأشياء المجهولة ، وهناك بعض الأشياء التي
تعلمناها خلال الأيام القليلة الماضية على
سبيل المثال ، علمنا أن الأشخاص يمكن أن
يكونوا بدون أعراض تمامًا ولا تظهر عليهم
أعراض  على الإطلاق وما زلنا نحمل
الفيروس وقد رأينا أيضًا حالة واحدة على الأقل
يبدو أنها تشير إلى أن شخصًا ما
يمكن أن ينقل الفيروس قبل أو
بعد ظهور أي أعراض ، لذا فإن كل هذه
البيانات الجديدة هي نوع من التوجيه لهذه القرارات
التي  نرى على المستوى الفيدرالي
يوجه شيئًا لم يتم القيام
به منذ خمسة عقود في هذا البلد مرة أخرى في
محاولة لمحاولة تقليل المخاطر
إليك